e aí vem a catarina deixou uma aqui com
alguns problemas eu sou professora de
formação e de coração e sempre tive na
minha vida como a gente tem dois braços
e duas pernas a sentir dois anos não
quero fazer o mar que tal mas tem sempre
o amor do ensino e o amor daquilo que me
foi dado durante toda a vida que eu
gosto de seria e o gosto as nossas
raízes e eu tenho sempre muito orgulho
em dizer que os meus pais não sendo de
maranhense de nascimento foram no
coração e como os grandes responsáveis
para que porque muitas das nossas
sensações não se tenham perdido que
realmente secretaria da ana lívia senão
assim um grande do motor da continuidade
da promoção do principalmente o curso
conventuais de guimarães eu coloquei
extremamente surpreendida quando recebi
o convite para participar a quina no
caderno a
eu escutei nas pernas muito cuidado o
quê que ainda mais surpreendida quando
me disseram o tema que ser algo tenho
ocupado um carinho do pensamento destes
últimos anos até uns anos tive uma coisa
e assim o 30 anos e anos e anos maluca
por em frente ao carro mas consegui
postar móveis limpar atrás limpável as
tomadas então não sei que até que um dia
para ir aí tu apaga quando tivesse com
treinos na altura eu era muito nova
portanto se compararmos era uma
resolveria agora quando eu tivesse
procurando olhar para trás e vou dizer
assim tem que aceitar minha vida untei
arrumei o que é que eu obtive disso
bom então signo.no frio essa minha praia
conseguiu com uma altura em que eu por
obrigação profissional que estava ao
destas condensado encontrei um autor
fantástico que se chama resolver e lhe
uma obra que mudou para sempre o meu
pensamento foi a aparição e o que é que
me ficou ali da aparição este este
acertar é do nome da terra mas vai um
cadinho ao encontro daquilo também estou
dizendo atualização e uma atenção dos
dias já não posso final a minha verdade
é aquilo que me sobra
o som da minha vida a quem sabe que tem
estou felicidade não estão no que nos
acontece mas que acontecem nós vê se
acontecer o que nos cobra não é que o
que nós temos que nos constrói aquilo
que nós obtemos daquilo que nós temos
nós temos que tudo e não obter nada
porque de facto nós muitas vezes temos
que largar tudo e ficar sem nada para
quem estuda e vou te apresentar aqui
comigo três pessoas estão ligadas da
minha vida por razões diferentes e que
eu admiro muito abrir temos a carla mota
e acaba bota é minha colega aqui pro
grafia o namorado é porque eu
físico-química e externas decidiram
deixar tudo
me pediram licença sem vencimento e vão
ao encontro tudo carregar estão a fazer
volta muito
a passar toda a dizer muitas vezes é
sério eu abrir o que de jantar fora com
meu marido ou namorado fabricamos ter um
carros competiu ovos e carnes ter o meu
apartamento não sei o quê mas é isso não
escreve
a partir tem leite a minha sobrinha
linda a seguir
e a tia entrou em arquitetura da
universidade do minho com quase média do
canal
o tempo de repente potente como
arquiteta
e você no primeiro semestre se de
lagarto a minha irmã e meu cunhado
eletrônico ainda me lembro desse a e
pediu largar tudo para seguir aquilo que
ela gosta a música
e as plantas vão ganhar 1000 2000 3000
responder
eu tenho pai a mãe quer ajuda na verdade
fazendo casa na fabricação e no século i
a
oi olha aquela lá tá suzana suzana é um
negócio famalicão uma desculpa não sabia
era que eu conheci hoje primeiro
famalicão que fazer um julho ea lua de
mel dela foi com o marido para pemba em
moçambique fazer voluntariado durante o
metro
oi suzana teria passar uma lua de mel
cancún resort futebol a suzana podia ter
feito tudo mais alguma coisa não sei que
ela aqui então maneiro essa escolha na
semana passada falei com ela e ela
estava na dizer que estava a partir para
a segunda missão
e ela não tem nada pelos lápis de grande
você está cansado mas ela finalmente
alguém encontrou o seu previsão
propriedades muito todos dizendo que
importante foi passando com a minha vida
de várias maneiras em que deixaram de
facto tudo abdicaram de ter muita coisa
mas aí foram obter também muita coisa ok
será que inteiro do carmo
é mas apoio do outro lado
é aquele lado quem não obtém nada de
tudo que dá este mapa que eu vou porque
a mostrar é um mapa do país com mais
altas taxas de suicídio e este mata foi
publicado em outubro segurança a pouco
dia mundial do facebook e este mapa é
nesta altura que também nós temos ali
aqueles que são os países que não estou
temos aqui aqueles que são os países que
nós normalmente associamos
em apenso onde as pessoas têm tudo
o canadá os cães nórdicos austrália
g1
há 8
eu tenho está conseguir todas tem
dinheiro pra os grandes
a resposta é
a não ser quando as taxas de suicídio
são mais altas e
é bastante um outro tenho nada daquilo
que tenho
eu te contar que eu ter não vai levar ao
forno e aqui vou lembrar de ver no
ferreira eu perguntava por que que
procuras a noite quando não suporta do
dia
a esta questão porque é que nós não se
importar no dia
e o que que há em nós que nos leva
tantas vezes a procurar a noite e eu não
sermos capazes de enfrentar a luz do dia
e às tantas por causa dos tipos de
woofer atendidos na atenção a minha
presença de minha mente próprio ea tudo
que me cerca de dentro de mim que eu sei
não do olhar do sul e uma explosão das
muitas vezes que eu sinto às vezes
andamos à procura de nós nos outros
e às vezes andamos à procura do tubo
e o namorado
as músicas temos que dentro de nós pode
estar e tudo não há um poema de pessoa
que amanhã 12º ano vamos aquele poema
que aí nós quieto não fala vasilha
transe total aliás não era lá que está
dentro de nós e não se esquece temos que
sempre não está tudo e andamos à procura
dos outros mas logo em duas coisas
desculpa será que alguém que eu acho
fantástico um pouquinho nem e os
influências acredito no inglês porque
assim da da nível vai ficar assim
portugueses influenciadores era um
bocado de vez não é então aparecer que
nós andávamos o que fazer lavagem
cerebral mas olha influências aí já os
servidores da opinião para saber o que o
pino maker corredores opinião mas que
diabos você não preciso que alguém faça
opinião que eu tenho outras coisas
o papagaio aqui alguém andar ganhar
dinheiro e eu ser todo até agraciado com
prévios o que está a fazer aquilo que
não devia fazer
eu vou tentar sinhá não é só posso
pintar o cabelo de vez em quando para
dispersar os bancos mas é para perguntar
é que eu perdi minha opinião
e eu tenho aninhos para testar com a
minha volta e eu tenho um vizinhos para
ouvir o que as pessoas dizem
bom então a calcinha para filtrar para
pensar para catarina opinião
e nós não temos tantas vezes aqui cegos
empregados conversas opinião conhece
influenciadores que tais como sexo
esquecimento procurar dentro de nós
aquilo que é importante e procurando com
nos outros e o que é que os outros
querendo nos ou está certo desculpa lá
oi ó tá ali atrás a gente tem poderes
que é que eu gostei não querem que eu
tenha uma carreira de sucesso olha então
porque no final do estava a falar que eu
te amo anos minha colega estava aí
porque teve os meus filhos deles porque
o que quero é que sua filha está em
seguida eu na minha inocência que elas
vocês tentarem são dizer eu quero que os
mesmos sejam boas pessoas e sejam
felizes é pa que fosse um bocado o final
então estejam aqui é não sei quem não
sabe por quê porque eu começo a pensar
há pessoas que chegam a 30 aquela água
se 40 anos tem o ator sua carreira já
tenho um carro topo de gama tem uma casa
que bateu os assuntos que vender porque
a grande mais perigoso e por que não
conseguem da primeira casa casa grande
o youtube músicas tem o que que ele sabe
tiveram
e aquelas pessoas que dizem que só
querem apaga só quer ter um de nós temos
felizmente para a sua vez liberdade para
ter sido escritos só quero ter um filho
que acreditar tudo mas o que é que está
tudo às tantas eu vou mostrar tudo mas
eles não vão obter nada daquilo que eu
toro
ah se eu pudesse lado que eu mandasse as
urtigas aquilo que os outros não fizeram
eu começasse a ser aquele beijo certo é
uma frase fabricantes fabricantes que
não reclame não vem ao caso daquele que
não vem mais não é
eu vou ver campos viveu no início do
século 20 é verdade verdadinha
e nós não estamos a ser o que nós
queremos ser estamos aqui assim nem tudo
bem nada assim não é só um bocadinho que
eu quero mas eu não sei se vou fazer
isso bastante a ficar na lista
e agora vou passar para mim
e em 1982 e os ajudava os meus pais não
passaríamos anos porque eu não sei se
jesus não tivesse ir para o trabalho
antes mas a minha mãe trabalha santiago
era coisa que linda tia nunca fiquei
traumatizada nha foi sempre muito boa
aluna e trabalhei sempre muito achas da
manhã apanha matei a limpar o passeio
para minha mãe para o cabeleireiro nunca
morrer por causa disso e
e eu tinha 82 pude ir uma das minhas
paixões eu estava morto viverá na altura
entre a filosofia o ensino associa a
história ea literatura desculpa o meu
curso por causa de inglês e depois o
cabelo crescer em inglês e ficar com
certeza né são essas coisas este tudo
que às vezes ficar bem nada nunca mais
ninguém nunca me atende não tem uma
altura é que eu comecei a pensar nesta
vida toda mas procurem que eu conheci
usou ferreira na em que eu comecei a
pensar nestas coisas entre feira e obter
e comecei a pensar no aniversário tudo
bem até de uma corretora tá mais ou
menos seus tipo nas tuas aulas respirar
para não morrer e sabes eles não é oque
o povo até curto mais ou menos nunca
vida não é feita de rodrigo tu tens vai
chegar a forma eu quero ficar só me
buscar mas eu não aturo pensava que eu
tenho agora já não sei e o que que tu
vai fazer
g1
ah e tu vai deixar o teu amor não
e o pai sempre tomar um conta de bateria
deste dentro do forno sempre grandes
pioneiros vamos abrir a sua vida parte
do para todos nós e acho que foi isso
foi este pensar entreter e obter esta és
tu querer obter alguma coisa da vida uma
boa não visitar tanto foi preciso de
oração é claro que contem sempre com o
apoio da mulher madalena sofia a novela
muito mais problema ficamos mais bonita
nos pronto lado e pacto e o acho que
aquilo que eu tenho na minha vida
não existe neste tudo que é facto esta
sensação
e tu não é não era de facto material
olha só sabe muito mais ter em casa
estamos muita dor de cabeça e isso mas
muita muita muita coisa é um bocado a
perguntaram-me como embaixo a fazer
tapete muito obrigada uma coisa que um
rebuliço e pacto tenho muito orgulho de
ter uma embaixadora de guimarães por
este país fora e já temos então nós
estamos em levar o nome de guimarães é
sempre um grande orgulho
o que realmente este querer
e ter tudo no sentido em que de tudo que
eu faço na vida e eu obtenho alguma
coisa eu vou terminar amanhã
apresentação com a referência um pano de
cabelo ainda coração número não consegue
desligar da poesia e eras tá certo de um
poema de cabelo que eu acho que é
fantástico fiz assim se depois de eu
morrer quiserem escrever a minha
biografia não há nada mais só tem duas
datas a da minha nascença ea da minha
morte entre uma e outra coisa todos os
dias são meus sou fácil de definir
bom dia fernanda nada a meias coisas sem
sentimentalidade nenhuma nunca tive um
desejo que não pudesse realizar porque
nunca
o bruno não é eu não posso te agarrar as
coisas elas não estão minhas eu posso
ter tudo e de repente ficar zangada é
é mas que o homem não se pode tenha
alguma coisa que eu tenho realidade tudo
porque muitas peguei um
a pipoca de tudo aquilo que eu tive eu
consigo por alguma coisa e tá pronto ó
e aí